[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara halweg Samstagabend willkommen
schön dass Sie dabei sind wie auch
Norbert Lehmann für den Sport heute
Terror in Jerusalem zwei Attentate
innerhalb von 24 Stunden erschüttern
Israel die Angst vor der nächsten
Eskalation in Nahost wächst
tödliche Verkehrskontrolle in den USA
prügeln fünf Polizisten brutal auf einen
Mann ein er stirbt die Debatte über
Polizeigewalt ist neu entfacht
und WM Goldrausch in Oberhof
Deutschlands rennrodelteam räumt fast
alles ab im Einsitzer Rasen die Frauen
auf Platz 1 2 und 3
[Musik]
die Reaktionen auf die Anschläge in
Israel sind einhellig Deutschland die
USA die Vereinten Nationen und selbst
Saudi-Arabien verurteilen die Angriffe
und warnen dass die Situation zwischen
Palästinensern und Israelis weiter
eskalieren könnte gestern starben in
Jerusalem acht Menschen heute griff ein
13-Jähriger Palästinenser jüdische
Siedler an Michael Beverungen
Erschütterung steht in den Gesichtern
keine 24 Stunden nach dem blutigsten
Attentat der letzten Jahre geht der
Terror weiter wieder im von Israel
annektierten Ost Jerusalem wieder gegen
orthodoxe Juden das Feindbild ist klar
der Attentäter diesmal ein 13-jähriger
Junge der seine Waffe durchlädt in
diesem Konflikt werden selbst Kinder zu
Tätern gemacht er schießt zwei Menschen
nieder bevor er selbst von bewaffneten
Passanten angeschossen wird alle
überleben aber das Entsetzen steigt und
der Hass
die Regierung muss ganz klar sein
niedermähen und ganz jennyen verbrennen
keine Soldaten mit Flammenwerfern von
oben was sie hier machen vergelten wir
Ihnen dort jeden Tag 3.000 Beerdigungen
nur so verstehen sie es
gestern hatte ein 21-jähriger
Palästinenser sieben synagogenbesucher
erschossen bevor er selbst getötet wurde
Terror der in den Straßen von Gaza
gefeiert wird die Hamas bekennt sich zu
dem Anschlag als Rache für eine
israelische Militäraktion in Genin bei
der am Donnerstag 8 palästinensische
Kämpfer und eine Zivilistin getötet
worden die Spirale der Gewalt dreht sich
immer schneller in Israel fordert der
rechtsextreme Sicherheitsminister die
aus seiner Sicht illegalen Bauten von
Palästinensern in Ost Jerusalem sofort
einzureißen so wie eine Nationalgarde
aufzubauen und als erstes müssen wir die
Todesstrafe für Terroristen auf den Weg
bringen und ich fordere premier und
Finanzminister darauf möglichst schnell
möglichst viele waffenlizenzen
auszugeben auch Ministerpräsident
netanjaro kündigte gestern am Tatort
sofortige Schritte an welche sagte er
nicht zur Stunde berät das
Sicherheitskabinett über das weitere
Vorgehen
Michael Beverungen tel aviven was macht
die Situation derzeit so gefährlich
die Brisanz liegt darin dass beide
Seiten eine Art unheilvolle Verbindung
eingehen auf der einen Seite die
Terrororganisation haben was und
islamischer ji hat deren Ziel ist es
möglichst viel Gewalt Chaos Aufruhr zu
stiften am besten einen arabisch
israelischen Bürgerkrieg und dieses
Strategie die trifft nur noch eine
religiös nationalistische Regierung die
glaubt Gewalt am besten mit Gegenwart zu
bekämpfen und das könnte am Ende dazu
führen dass sich dieser Konflikt nur
noch weiter hochschaukelt
vielen Dank für diese Einschätzung aus
Tel Aviv Michael Beverungen war das
die Ukraine meldet weiter schwere
russische Angriffe im Osten des Landes
vor allem in der Region Donetsk in der
Stadt Christian tenifka sein bei einem
Angriff auf ein Wohngebiet mindestens
drei Menschen ums Leben gekommen
besonders im Visier stünden auch wuchle
da und bachmut Russland versucht in der
Region seit Monaten die ukrainischen
Frontlinien zu durchbrechen
der Krieg in der Ukraine die Energie und
rohstoffkrise das sind Themen auf der
ersten Reise des Bundeskanzlers nach
Südamerika Olaf Scholz wird von einem
Dutzend Managern und Verbandsvertretern
begleitet es geht nach Argentinien Chile
und Brasilien ziel ist die
Zusammenarbeit im Wettbewerb mit
Russland und China zu verstärken
in Tschechien steht seit wenigen Stunden
fest wer neuer Präsident wird
diese beiden Kandidaten standen zur Wahl
der Pro westliche
ex-generalpatrib Basel und der für
seinen Populismus bekannte
ex-regierungs-
das Ergebnis der Stichwahl ist eindeutig
rund 58 Prozent der Stimmen gingen an
Petri Pavel aus Prag Britta Hilpert
nicht lang nach den Schließen der
Wahllokale ist klar Tschechiens neuer
Präsident ist Peter Pavel der Ex-General
will nun das Land einen er will die
Ordnung wiederherstellen wie er sagt der
Wahlkampf hat tiefe Spuren hinterlassen
Werte die Wahrheit würde Respekt und
Demut
Verlierer andre Babisch hatte einen
schmutzigen Wahlkampf geführt general
Pavel wolle Krieg nur Erding Frieden
Peters Information mobilisierte Gegner
und Fans gewählt und weil er will
Frieden da bestellte sogar die NATO
Bündnis Treue in Frage im Angriff auf
Partner wie Polen
definitiv keine tschechischen Soldaten
zu Verteidigung schicken Kopfschütteln
bei Pavel und bei vielen Nachbarn in
Europa Prag musste Bündnis Treue zu
sicher
Desinformation und Polarisierung trieben
die Wahlbeteiligung auf Rekordhöhe viele
Welten gegen barbisch mehr als für Paare
was ich wähle Pavel damit ich mich nicht
für meinen Präsidenten schämen muss
sagen er ist super ich kann nur sagen er
ist auf jeden Fall das geringere Übel
[Musik]
Tschechiens Wahlergebnis wird wohl in
vielen europäischen Hauptstädten ein
Seufzer der Erleichterung auslösen nicht
nur in der NATO gilt Ex-General Pavel
als sicherere Bank Anfang März sieht
Peter Pavel in die Prager Burg als
Präsident und Oberbefehlshaber der Armee
nach China experten hatten gewarnt dass
chinesische Neujahrsfest werde zum
tödlichen Corona superspredder Event
weil plötzlich wieder Millionen von
Menschen auf Reisen sind und das Virus
übertragen die offiziellen Todeszahlen
werden darüber keine verlässliche
Auskunft geben deshalb hat unsere China
Korrespondentin Elisabeth Schmidt andere
Quellen gesucht um der Realität näher zu
kommen
in mibet-
südlich von Peking sind sie auf
Totenkult spezialisiert Blumen
papierpuppen Papiergeld ein E-Bike ein
Pferd hier gibt es alles was im Jenseits
Glück und Wohlstand bringen soll dieser
Ladeninhaber erzählt uns er habe noch
nie so viel verkauft wie in den
vergangenen Wochen
schauen Sie sich unsere Regale an hier
gibt es fast nichts mehr auch unsere
beiden Lager sind leer wir machen gerade
sehr viel Umsatz
abseits der großen Städte finden wir
weitere Belege dafür dass die Zahl der
Kurve Toten weit höher sein muss als die
chinesischen Behörden angeben auf den
Feldern unzählige Erdhügel viele sind
mit Blumen geschmückt diese Landarbeiter
bestätigen uns dass es neue Gräber sind
wir fragen ob die Menschen an Corona
gestorben sind ja an koved es sind viel
mehr Leute gestorben als sonst sogar aus
Peking haben sie ihre Toten hierher
gebracht erzählen die Arbeiter weil sie
in den Krematorien in der Hauptstadt zu
lange warten mussten
die meisten Infektionen habe es hier
Ende Dezember gegeben erfahren wir die
Menschen die zurzeit sterben sein oft
weit über 80 Jahre die Asche auf dem
Boden stammt von Papierblumen dass für
die Toten verbrannt wurde die Erde die
Blumen sind noch frisch also dieses Grab
ist relativ neu und es gibt viele davon
hier die Toten die hier liegen tauchen
nicht in der offiziellen Statistik auf
denn sie zählt nur Menschen die in einer
Klinik an Kurve gestorben sind aber hier
auf dem Land steht oft kein Arzt zur
Verfügung um den Tod feststellen wenn
jemand in seinem Haus gestorben ist wie
viele Menschen in China in Zusammenhang
mit dem Coronavirus gestorben sind kann
deshalb nur geschätzt werden die genaue
Zahl werden wir wohl nie erfahren
in den USA herrscht einmal mehr
Fassungslosigkeit über die Brutalität
einiger Polizisten vor fast drei Wochen
starb ein 29-jähriger Vater nachdem ihn
Polizisten bei einer Kontrolle zu Tode
geprügelt haben jetzt wurde das Video
des Einsatzes veröffentlicht es ist
verstörend allerdings geht es in diesem
Fall wohl nicht um Rassismus denn nicht
nur das Opfer ist schwarz sondern auch
die mutmaßlichen Täter Benjamin Daniel
berichtet
prügelnde US-Polizisten schon wieder
tyronicles versucht zu flüchten nachdem
die Polizei ihn angehalten hatte Taser
tritt der Tränengas die Beamten richten
den 29-Jährigen dermaßen zu dass er im
Krankenhaus stirbt am Ende seines Lebens
steht der Hilfeschrei nach seiner Mutter
keine Mutter sollte Ihr Kind auf solch
eine brutale Weise verlieren wie ich
mein Kind verloren habe
in den USA sorgt Polizeigewalt gegen
schwarze immer wieder für Entsetzen so
hatte 2020 in Minneapolis ein Polizist
George Floyd so lange sein Knie auf den
Hals gepresst bis er starb anders als
bei der Gewalttat von Memphis ging es
damals um weiße Beamte der aktuelle Fall
zeigt dass die Polizei in Amerika nicht
nur ein Rassismusproblem hat Joe Biden
setzte sich schon damals für eine
umfassende polizei-reform
es geht hier auch um das Image von
Amerika darum ob wir das Land sind dass
wir behaupten zu sein
ein Land in dem Recht und Ordnung
herrschen
die Reform scheiterte schließlich am
Widerstand der Republikaner den nun
Festgenommenen Polizisten wird unter
anderem Mord zweiten Grades vorgeworfen
wir glauben dass das Video und die
anderen Beweise zeigen dass die
Angeklagten sich darüber im Klaren waren
dass ihre Handlungen ziemlich sicher zum
Tod des Opfers führen würden im ganzen
Land gehen Menschen auf die Straße auch
um für die für viele längst überfällige
Polizeireform zu demonstrieren es
scheint als kämpften sie auf verlorenem
Posten
[Musik]
[Applaus]
nach Deutschland die CDU will ihn am
liebsten loswerden und prüft derzeit
einen Parteiausschluss die
rechtskonservative werteunion wählte ihn
heute zu ihrem Vorsitzenden Hans-Georg
Maaßen früher
Verfassungsschutzpräsident er wolle sich
gegen jede Art von ökosozialismus und
genderwokismus einsetzen so Maßen auf
Twitter die werteunion ist eine Gruppe
von konservativen CDU-Mitgliedern aber
kein offizieller Teil der Partei
diese Zahl lässt aufhorchen 4,3
Milliarden Euro das ist die Summe aller
Gasrechnungen der Verbraucher für
Dezember die der Start bislang
übernommen hat die sogenannte Dezember
Soforthilfe ist die erste Stufe der
gaspreisbremse und soll den Anstieg der
Energiepreise dämpfen
Köln das war jahrelang der fortstandort
in Deutschland und ist es auch immer
noch doch ist drohen massive Einschnitte
Firmengründer Henry Ford legte 1930
selbst den Grundstein für das Werk schon
ein Jahr später liefen die ersten
Modelle vom Band der Beginn einer
amerikanisch rheinischen
Erfolgsgeschichte weil aber die
Glanzzeiten der verbrennerproduktion
vorbei sind will Ford ab 2030 in der EU
nur noch Elektroautos verkaufen und das
bedeutet wohlstellenabbau Lothar Becker
berichtet
vor allem hier im Entwicklungszentrum in
Köln Merkenich will Ford Stellen
streichen beim Treffen der
Vertrauensleute heute wurde erneut klar
die Unsicherheit in der Belegschaft ist
groß und kampflos will die IG Metall die
Entwicklungsabteilung in Köln nicht
aufgeben wenn wir diese Themen in
Zukunft nicht mehr machen dann wird
natürlich sind die Standorte in
Deutschland aber in Europa oder vor
Europa insgesamt was das Pkw-Segment
angeht bedroht und das natürlich unsere
wichtigste Aufgabe jetzt als Betriebsrat
diese Arbeitsplätze zu sichern seit
Jahrzehnten wurde und wird in Köln
designt was später hier auch vom Band
läuft oder in anderen Werken in Europa
und sogar weltweit wie zuletzt der Ford
Fiesta doch eine elektrische Version
wurde nicht entwickelt während gerade
aus Asien vor allem China neue
Hersteller auf den Markt drängen die
Branche durchläuft tatsächlich eine
fundamentale Transformation das ist
natürlich zum einen bedingt durch
Technologie neue Wettbewerber aber auch
ein stark verändertes Kundenverhalten
das zwingen insbesondere etablierte
Hersteller hier Geschäftsmodell neu
auszurichten und auch effizienter zu
gestalten so sitzt fort bei den E-Autos
die ab diesem Jahr in Köln gebaut werden
auf eine Allianz mit Volkswagen die
Konkurrenz liefert die Plattform fort
adaptiert diese nur noch spart so
langjährige Entwicklungskosten und will
auch künftig E-Autos ohne die Kölner
Entwicklungsabteilung konstruieren dafür
brauche ich qualifizierte Ingenieure
Ingenieurin und ITler die habe ich auch
hier in Köln am Standort deswegen
akzeptieren wir das nicht das hier der
Kahlschlag stattfinden soll fort hat den
Gewerkschaften inzwischen konstruktive
Gespräche versprochen wie viele Stellen
genau betroffen sind sollen Mitte
Februar bekannt gegeben werden
die Nordinsel Neuseelands wird seit
Tagen von verheerenden Regenfällen
heimgesucht betroffen ist vor allem die
größte Stadt Auckland mindestens drei
Menschen starben in den Fluten einer
wird vermisst die Behörden sprachen vom
nassesten Tag seit Beginn der
Wetteraufzeichnungen und riefen die 1,6
Millionen Bewohner zu äußerster Vorsicht
auf
und jetzt in den Schnee die Erfolgsserie
bei der rodelheim WM in Oberhof reißt
nicht ab ja gestern gab es ja schon
viermal Gold und heute kommen drei
weitere WM Titel dazu einmal bei den
Männern zweimal bei den Frauen ja und da
gab es im Einsitzer sogar eine deutschen
dreifach Triumph angeführt von
annabereiter die Athletin vom Königssee
kann ihr Glück über den ersten WM-Titel
ihrer Karriere kaum fassen sie beweist
Nerven Stärke und verteidigt ihre
Führung aus dem ersten Lauf souverän
Julia taubitz und Diana Eichberger
sorgen mit Silber und Bronze für einen
deutschen dreifach Erfolg
im Doppelsitzer erfolgreich vor Tobias
wendel und Tobias alt und das
medaillenfeuerwehr komplettiert der
Doppelsitzer Degen hat Rosenthal bei den
Frauen mit der insgesamt 7 Goldmedaille
für die deutschen rot oder bei dieser
Heim WM
[Musik]
skispringerin Katharina Althaus hat auch
den zweiten Heimweltcup der Saison
gewonnen in Hinterzarten siegte sie
souverän vorweltmeisterin Emma klingerts
und
ski-rennläuferin Lena Dürr die wurde
beim Weltcup im tschechischen
Spindlermühle im Slalom zweite hinter
US-Superstar Michaela Schiffe
das Internationale Olympische Komitee
trotz des Ukraine Kriegs die Teilnahme
russischer und belarussischer
Athletinnen und Athleten an
internationalen Wettbewerben ermöglichen
IOC-Präsident Bach verteidigte die Pläne
heute in einem ZDF Interview als
Besucher der Rodel werden in Oberhof
euc-präsident thomas Bach auf heikler
Mission unter strikten Vorgaben könnten
Athletinnen aus Russland und Belarus
wieder olympischen Sport teilnehmen das
heißt keine Flagge keine Hymne keine
Uniformen keine
Regierungsvertreter dieser beiden
Nationen der Präsident der Ukraine
reagiert mit scharfer Kritik
die olympischen Prinzipien und Krieg
stehen in einem fundamentalen Gegensatz
zueinander
Deutschland leben sind hin und
hergerissen so solange dieser Krieg
wirklich dort andauern andauert ja
sollte man das beibehalten so wie es
jetzt einfach ist um ukrainische
Sportlerinnen zu schützen hat der Rodel
Weltverband Russland weiterhin komplett
ausgesperrt noch
beim Tennis dürfen ja schon bei einigen
Turnieren Sportler aus Belarus und
Russland teilnehmen und eine dieser
sogenannten neutralen Athletin hat
erstmals einen Tennis grand slam-turnier
gewonnen Arena sabalenca aus Belarus
besiegte im Finale der Australian Open
Gewinner über China in drei Sätzen und
nun zum ersten Rückrunden spieltag in
der Fußball-Bundesliga der Sieger in
Berliner Stadt Derby heißt Union hier
die bisherigen Ergebnisse
die Hertha verliert das hauptstatuellen
mit 0:2 Hoffenheim unter die Gladbach
klar mit 1:4 Bremen bezwingt Wolfsburg
mit 2:1 Schützenfest in Mainz die 05er
schlagen Bochum mit 5:2 Freiburg gewinnt
gegen Augsburg 3:1 das Abendspiel
München gegen Frankfurt bereits gestern
besiegte Leipzig Stuttgart mit 22:21 zur
Tabelle die Bayern bleiben diesen
Spieltag auf jeden Fall Spitzenreiter
zur Zeitpunkt gleich mit Union Leipzig
Dritter Freiburg klettert wieder auf
einen Champions League Platz Frankfurt 5
Dortmund 6er Wolfsburg und in der
zweiten Tabellenhälfte geht's für Bremen
und Mainz nach den Heimsiegen jeweils
einen Platz hoch ja und dann Tabellen
Ende alles unverändert Bochum Hertha und
schlosslicht Schalke
und das Topspiel Bayern gegen Frankfurt
nachher bei uns im Aktuellen Sportstudio
ausführlich 23 Uhr vielen Dank die Nacht
wird eisig und deswegen gilt es
vorsichtig zu sein wegen Glättegefahr
mehr dazu gleich von ostentherly
Christian Sievers begrüßt sie um viertel
elf im heute-journal und wir wünschen
Ihnen noch ein schönes Wochenende und
alles Gute bis morgen wenn Sie mögen auf
Wiedersehen
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter derzeit haben wir
es mit relativ ruhigen Wetter zu tun
aber eine Kaltfront nähert sich von
Nordwesten her und bringt etwas Regen
mit dieser Regen gefriert dann auf den
eisigen Böden z.B in der kommenden
nachts nach Nordosten hin der Regen
wandert langsam in den Süden Schnee kann
auch dabei sein ja und ganz im Süden
wird es ebenfalls glatt dort durch reif
Glätte teilweise ist es neblig und bei
Temperaturen bis minus 11 Grad kann es
eben ebenfalls glatt werden frostfrei
ist es Richtung Norden und am mildesten
noch an der Nordsee mit plus 4 Grad
morgen dann im Süden viel Sonnenschein
Richtung Donau allerdings noch relativ
lange nämlich trüb wenn der Nebel sich
auflöst kommt dann die Sonne hervor nach
Nordosten den gibt's noch Regen am
Vormittag der kann durchaus noch für
rutschige Straßen sorgen aber dann
verabschiedet sich das allmählich ganz
im Nord meisten gibt es ebenfalls etwas
Regen bei höchsten Temperaturen von -2
bis plus 7 Grad an der Nordsee deutlich
milder oder am Montag wird es
ungemütlich mit Regen Schnee und
Gewittern dazu Sturm bei ein bis neun
Grad ein schöner Abend